[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to GameSpot
we are here covering III 2018
I'm really excited we are starting our
live stage demos here today now the
press conferences are all sorted out I'm
Mike McCarty I will be here with Lucy
James throughout the week and we've got
a full three days ahead of us of some
great developers I'm really excited for
this one Brian - our creative director
at insomniac games on spider-man yeah
thanks for having a great way to kick
off the show what better way than a
spider-man come on yeah what was it like
showing off that trailer last night
nervous panicked but excited at the same
time we're pretty pumped yeah you got
the show off with the sinister six
toward the end we got we saw mr.
negative we saw em I know I know
scorpion yeah yeah let's go on tonight
people said they want you know before
this show like we hope we see one
villain we're like one's not enough
let's just go you know three or four
more yeah it was awesome and then I know
you're doing hands-on demos as well
right yeah that's by far the more
nerve-racking if you actually put the
controller in people's hands and let
them actually play because really very
few people have ever played the game
till last night yeah so what did you
what we're gonna be looking at on the
demo today yeah so actually I'm Adam one
of our combat designers is gonna be
jumping into what do what do you want to
do is farm in you want to swim around
New York City so he's actually I'm gonna
be swinging around and doing a bunch of
different activities awesome right yeah
I mean it's been since uh spider-man two
days I think I'd spend since I really
felt like it was I mean there were a lot
of spider-man games but that's the lot
the one that I feel like everybody's
always chasing was I think I think for
most people that's kind of the moment
that they became big spider-man video
game fans was actually the fulfilling of
fantasies being spider-man in an open
world and you know obviously we're big
fans in that game and a lot of the other
spider-man games at least want to take
what people loved about those games but
do it in our way yeah what's it what's
it like I mean having to make in it like
a superhero game in general I mean it's
like I said both exhilarating and scary
at the same time I think when we first
found out we were to make spider-man
your instant reaction is - it's a fan
boy out and go okay well I want to see
this villain and I want to do this and
then
reality sets in that you have to make a
game yeah what argument most one of the
most popular characters in the world and
then you start to get really scared I
think he just trying to figure out well
what do people love about the character
he's funny he's relatable
he's a sense of vulnerability but he's
also got these super awesome powers and
finding the DNA the character we're also
kind of putting our own twist on it
awesome
well I would love to see some gameplay I
think we're on the backer death so Adams
gonna start up I set up the demo and you
know of course first so you can pull the
bass down and get an action awesome
right so obviously we're looking here
this is spider-man over Manhattan and
walk us through this yes so essentially
you know that last night ad at the Sony
press conference we showed you know one
of our main story missions so obviously
we have our you know a great big story
and people that have these big missions
but at the same time there's a whole
other element to the world and that's
you know obviously playing through
swinging through New York City and
finding different activities so you know
people always wonder well it's an open
world I'm like yes it's a very big open
world so actually Adams taking you over
to kind of a quick kind of combat
tutorial we want to kind of get people
up to speed on the different abilities
so you know one thing is you know our
spider-man has been doing this for eight
years so he definitely has a sense a
level of mastery of skills it's all
about him being improvised her using
acrobatics using webs I'm using gadgets
and a lot of environmental X you kind of
have a lot of player choice as you're
going so Adam makes it look really
really good and we want it players to
have that sense of obviously I pick up
and play nature to it but also as you
get really good you can do things like
we saw and that um that raft on the last
night right what are some places you
look for inspiration for combat I think
I mean obviously we look at the DNA to
care for right you know we want he's
very acrobatic we want to get him off
the ground we want to use webs but then
we look to look at you know some great
action games you know yes we have played
Batman everybody got we would be silly
not to play Batman and right at that
game because it's a it's a fantastic
franchise broselow key things like
definitely cry and you know any big
third party you know action game
we just look at and look for inspiration
but same time make make it our own you
know one thing is I actually it was a
GameSpot article I read and it was one
of it was like eight things we want to
see in spider-man yeah and I remember
one of the bullet points being we want
to feel like an insomniac game there was
something like that though it was really
important to us to deliver on the
spiderman fantasy but also deliver on
what people expect from an insomniac
game so you know you're gonna see a lot
of gadgets you're gonna see a lot of
suit powers suit modifications to add
that that tech that that gadget that not
only sparked known for but so are we
and it was actually an article you know
not to say cuz I'm on gave but it was
something I actually sent out the team
going this is people wanted to be an
assignment game as much as they want to
be a Spartan game so we really we found
that and that's one kind of the game
really gel that's kind of taking what we
love about spider-man what we love about
the games that we make and bringing them
together I mean obviously traversal was
very much inspired by our time with
sunset overdrive and then adding that
and then same thing with you know all
the different abilities gadgets that he
can craft definitely feels it like a
game that we've been making you know it
feels like you know people who are
insomniac fans will also want to give it
a chance one of the questions I want to
ask you the game played um you showed
off last year there were quite a lot of
QuickTime events listen II know but
electricity and video games they're
adding more accessibility options
together there's help people who maybe
aren't gonna be able to hit it up that
every time have you got any plans for
those yeah we definitely will have
accessibility options to make sure that
you know one is we don't have a ton of
cuties there very very few and far
between kind of more for some of the
some big moments but yeah we definitely
want player as many people place as
possible so we will have accessibility
options to make things like a QuickTime
super easy or just you know self
complete and stuff like that we'll
probably talk more about that in the
months to come but yeah we want them to
be as accessible as we can right what is
uh when it comes to choosing from
spider-man I like what I like about this
game already is that we're not gonna see
Peter Park of a coming spider-man yeah
gonna see Uncle Ben dying here
we're getting straight in he's been
doing this for a few years
yeah
how do you then kind of like take on the
choice cuts of like however many dozens
of years of spider-man yeah so in the
very first month of the game of
development we said two things one it
won't be an origin story and those webs
better attach to buildings like that was
our two-bit right off the bat I think
you know it was we knew obviously we're
not going to be a movie tie-in and we
weren't gonna be just try to kind of
take one of the comic story lines which
are great and just redo them we said
what wouldn't what fits the character
really well so let the DNA but then we
looked at like what could be at Tom in
his life that would be interesting you
know again a lot of yields on origin you
know the studio sod is has a has a
fifteen-year-old Peter Parker which is a
great juxtaposition compared to all the
other character fits really well so you
know I thought back to my time and my
life will when I graduate college that
was a very very memorable moment it was
the first time I'd be you know I was an
adult now I had to pay the bills I was
my first job that next come of age story
we thought that could be a really
interesting time in Peters life so
that's kind of what we thought that
would be a good time you know obviously
where he works will be a big thing in
the game we just thought that would be a
really fun time to explore both
narrative Lee but also from a gameplay
standpoint of having a long history of
some of these villains that you saw last
night or interesting new people like mr.
negative so just kind of that's my short
answer a long interesting it's really
freaking hard and we have a lot of
talented people who are smarter than me
to help figure it out imagine there must
be a lot of nerves working I mean this
goes back to like pre-production when
you found out that you're doing
spider-man what's it like working with a
pre-existing franchise as opposed to
like retching Clank sunset overdrive
stuff that insomnia created and
themselves so the joke I always say is
the greatest thing about working on
spider-man is that working on spider-man
and the hardest thing about working on
spider-man is that spider-man because
the character is so beloved by everybody
or so minute like I never have I can see
is you know you know with ratchet
resistance you got to have to kind of
help you know explain it sometimes you
can say I'm making spider-man and people
get it right but everybody comes about
this character different ways you know
for me it was comics and cartoons and
then it was the movies some people just
the movies right it's just like quite
learn about spider-man from the same
Raimi movies
so we all kind of have where do we get
in so everybody has an idea of well this
is who Peter Parker or spider-man is to
me well then you kind of okay we're not
going to recreate that version that you
have your head but what are the common
characteristics
it's the relatability it's the
vulnerability it's the worlds colliding
it's the would Peter fail spider myth
succeeds and vice versa the really
strong ties to the villains in his life
that you know they're like mr. negative
he owns runs feast Aunt May works at
feast you have those worlds colliding
taking those elements and that's what we
used to make the game and once you kind
of get that that you the nerves kind of
calmed down because you know you're
making the game in one way or another
that people will understand they'll
appreciate because it represents the DNA
the character that they loved was it
like working in collaboration with
Marvel so you know it's it's it's not
really working with them I mean I will
say they work they their office about 10
to 15 minutes from where we are in
Burbank ok so I just think of them and
this is truthfully there just insomniac
who happen to work 15 minutes down the
road you know bill Mike Eric they're
just they are part of the dev team you
know when we very rarely do we talk
obviously talk about Marvel and the you
know the lore and the brand but we
actually just talk more about like
developers like are we doing this is it
good for the story is it good for the
game they're just developers just like
we are so it's been supernatural I mean
it's they you know they're obviously
really great storytellers and they bring
a lot of experience there and at the
same time just as it's great working
Marvel having a partner like Sony it's
again it's been it's been fantastic it's
like they're just great I mean
everybody's loves games loves comics and
it's it's the fun partnership and you
get to put your own stamp on a character
that but most of us have grown up with
what yeah I know it's
I you know we say power responsibility
right we feel a lot of responsibility to
get the character right and it's I will
say this is the most surreal experience
working on this game I mean I'm sitting
here like staring at this giant
spider-man in the background behind my
shoulder and you know to see walking
into West Hall today and see spider-man
in the Convention Center exists it
career-wise it's a dream come true force
open myself and so many insomniac to be
working on something so memorable at the
same time working in Tomic we are
independent we can work on something as
amazing as spider-man but then we can
also be working on a VR title like storm
land or also you know working we work on
Fino ratchet so we have a lot of
flexibility as developer so we have the
best of all worlds I'm curious when you
look back at old spider-man games I mean
this kind of again goes back to the
drawing board but what were some things
that you thought that maybe games
haven't captured you mentioned Batman in
the Arkham trilogy I think that's widely
acknowledged as like when give
videogames finally got Batman right
right yeah I mean I'm sure you're hoping
that's the case of spider-man higher I
sure sure hope so I mean I have a lot
less hair on my head than I did before
but based on that that that worried
hopefully that was worth I think the I
think the thing that really what we
really want to do is we also wanted to
deliver the superhero fantasy if
swinging around New York City
fighting great super villains acrobatic
combat but I think what we really wanted
to set out with this game there's a
whole nother there's it's a very human
story I mean it's I say it's much much
of Peter Parker experience as it is a
spider-man experience and I think when
you look at the best comics the best
especially the movies these movies
resonate because there's a story beyond
just them being in the costumes so we
put a lot of time and effort and which
is really hard of when Peter's not
wearing this you when he's at work when
he's with MJ when he's he's talking to
Aunt May about life about life lessons
to us that's a it's so not important to
a great story but also to a spider-man
Peter Parker story so for me if we can
nail that I think we've done something
pretty special
another thing that's really at the heart
of spider-man is the humor like after
quit after quit like and humor in video
games is usually super hit or miss it's
it's infuriatingly hard like we we you
know he said pre-production right a lot
of that was funding the voice of
spider-man not only finding you know
what the humor is like how often it
happens you know very early on he was
just like equipping not softening it got
annoying and it's nothing to do with you
what are Yuri our actor in spider-man is
fantastic and he would you know he
worked a lot with us you know hey try
something different or just what's the
frequency you know a lot of the one
thing I noticed a lot is the best things
in the comics or the movies it's
situational humor it's not just a
one-off quip that's related to nothing
it's actually ready it specifically for
the situation our writers John Paquette
Ben Armand Christos Gage those guys just
nailed it and that's something we
fine-tuned over over the course of
development and now if it's really I
feel really good that we get we have the
voice I feel like URI does a great job
performing it but our writers and our
designers get really good job of finding
the right opportunities in the game to
deliver it right working on to really
comes out in September but you did it
I mean you think about it it first of
all the character so beloved that the
expectations are astronomical and you're
talking to somebody who I was someone
buying those games whether it's whether
it's spider-man Batman whatever you you
have such a attachment these characters
you want them to be grimy with although
the Marvel movies were like it's better
be good I grew up on these characters
they better get it right and now being a
group that has to get it right is a lot
um I think there's so many different
facets it's swinging is so important
right it's like if you don't nail that
it's like that's got to get in the door
just getting in and then it's okay the
combat and make you feel acrobatic and
making it you know right away feeling
like a superhero right away but having a
level of mastery and get in having that
sandbox environment and then and then
there's the whole story like you have to
be funny and he has to have that human
story so there's so many different
variables to get it right that that's
the challenge and that's what keeps me
up at night but luckily we've a very
talented team who they they're nailing
it
you mentioned the like a level of
mastery and none of it something very
interesting because obviously
spider-man's been doing this for a while
straight out of the gate is he gonna
have all of his abilities and stuff like
how are you gonna onboard that's a new
play it's great so right now in the demo
we added some training in a demo but
over the course of the game we we dull
things out like so one thing is we want
it we put you in the action right away
literally like the first thing the game
is you get a call fists tower get there
and you're falling but it's swinging
through New York City and we we give you
enough to make you feel like a superhero
right but then over the course of the
game you'll you'll earn XP you'll get
skill point you're unlock new skills new
suit mods and then we cut a dole it over
the course of time so as you know by the
time you played first couple hours
you're kind of in the groove right
thought arrows have a little mic problem
my mic it oh yeah so Micah yeah yeah
well I thought Lucy cut this alright and
just as we got to a little cutscene as
well yes so this is actually early on in
the game you run into your old pal
shocker who is who's what else robbing a
bank and you have you have a little boss
fight with him in this Bank and one
thing in point out was like obviously
not only from the story but also our
character designs we wanted to kind of
take you know respect to the Christians
of franchise you know that's a shocker
classic colors but also put our own
little twist on it so shocker is a good
example of that
and he basically gets really mad that
you stop them and he's decided to just
destroy the bank honey and try to try to
take you down so this is one of the
early boss fights in the game you know
one people last year were worried about
fear and have enough villains and
hopefully last night and this demo will
show people that we have plenty of
villains in the game
plenty of villains well Brian thank you
so much for coming down to talk to us um
thank can't wait to play spinal engine
telling everyone when it's out September
7th I bet it feels so good to say that
it does because for so many time I could
not say it so yes it feels really good
well thank you again and guys make sure
to stick around coming up next we're
gonna have dying light too
you